but there's a funny tweet from um Parker
I think it's Parker Thompson on Twitter
he he replied to that he goes okay so
for those Cupid score at home Elon Elon
brought a bought a product for 44
billion and then Zuck built the same
product for a thousand times less is
stealing all of his users like an
absolute Chad it is God willing about to
choke him out in 90 seconds on a steel
cage soon huh so that's what a cuff
means now
[Music]
laughs
all right what's up today's episode
we're talking about threads versus
Twitter the big debate and we're gonna
talk about where we where we land our
predictions for what you think is going
to happen how it's going to play out
um we told her some funny stories and
then in the second half we have a uh an
interview with a guy named Sam of it so
Sam met Sam met this guy Sam he used to
run a business called consulting.com
that at its peak hit 30 million in
Revenue he was all over our Facebook
feeds as kind of like one of these
internet marketer guys and so we were
curious like who is this guy and what's
he all about
um definitely an interesting interview I
would say uh he had some interesting
stuff to say also his energy was totally
different than most of the guests and
also different than what you would
expect out of an Internet marketer so
I'm curious to see what people think of
it
um I would say it's you know sort of
like a a different style of energy than
we've done before Sam what do you think
uh so for those watching on YouTube I'm
sweating right now the reason I'm
sweating is around minute 35.
I can't stop laughing I'm still laughing
about it you're gonna enjoy it the Taco
Bell story let's just leave it at that
oh my God it's ridiculous uh I don't
know like how this story came about in a
business pod I'm happy it did I'm
sweating right now if you are on Spotify
or apple and you're listening to this go
to our YouTube page uh search my first
million go to this episode let us know
in the comments what you think people
liked when we did that the last time
Sean we got a lot of comments a lot of
good feedback it's it's uh we actually
it's been fun to read all the comments
but let us know what you think
we'll talk to you soon
all right what's up
um Sam we gotta talk about
threads threads versus Twitter
it uh threads came out a few days ago
we've had a few days to play with it to
sit on it to think about it and
um I think everybody's given their
opinion on it
and why not ours I want to hear what you
get what you have to say about this I
have a
I have a I have kind of like a way I
think we could talk about this the what
I'm calling the Bull and Bear case or
the bull case the bear case and then
where we land but I first just want to
hear like I don't know when did you get
on it and what was your kind of initial
reaction how on your radar was this
thing to begin with
I had only heard about it three or four
days before it launched and I heard
about it because
of a leak I think there was a leak right
there somehow it leaked out that it was
coming out so I downloaded the app like
the you can download it before it
launched and then I got the notification
right at midnight or whenever it said it
launched and I signed up I think it's
pretty cool are you jealous that I
already have more followers than you do
on that because I was already going hard
on Instagram no well yeah yeah going
hard on Instagram paid off there uh you
got like a like a double bonus for for
growing your Instagram so so Props to
you on that
um I think it's great you know why I
think it's great I really only think
it's great for one reason which is
Twitter to me is pretty great but dude
my feed is just like fight videos and
people getting shot and dying like it's
real it's kind of become a little bit
sad that's unusual I also I don't know
anyone else's fault
just follow button and the like button
and the save button the algorithm will
just give you more look here's the deal
if you see like a fight video you watch
it like you're not not gonna watch that
it's like when you have a hot girl that
like Scrolls through like you you slow
you scroll slower does this get here
all right
yeah so it's just all these weird
handles I also think that I've I've
become such a stand for Zuck and this
whole thing he's just proven to be like
the man he's he's come off very likable
and so I find myself picking sides based
off of the owner of the company
yeah yeah it's become it's become Sports
it's become tribal whose team are you on
and I don't know how the hell I ended up
team Zuck but I'm like
I'm on team suck it's very obvious to me
it's very clear I think this guy's done
an incredible Rebrand of his personality
because he went from like
easy to hate for a bunch of reasons one
becomes rich and powerful people don't
like that
um two he looked like a robot talk like
a robot seem to have no personality so
you know that was you know again like
for the people who didn't get turned off
by the power and billionaire thing they
got turned off by like okay this guy's a
lizard or he's a robot like what's going
on with this guy
um
and then somehow
it's you know he hired the top top PR
agencies in the world he hired the fixer
the wolf came in and tried to fix him
all he needed to do was start working
out the guy guy takes 10 Jiu Jitsu
classes and learns how to do a pull-up
and all of a sudden idiots like us are
like you know what
I [__] with this guy yeah he's relatable
somehow yeah it totally worked on me and
then to the point where you start
thinking about it this happened also
with LeBron James LeBron James at one
point was he was super hyped then he
became the guy and then people started
to turn on him then he did this thing
where he left his team went to Miami and
everyone's like oh I hate this guy and
then somebody's pointing out they're
like so you're telling me this kid who
had all the pressure in the world
uh when he was 17 18 years old delivered
on the hype lived up to it never got in
trouble with the law you've never heard
about this guy you know married his high
school sweetheart is a good dad to his
kids
um you know is is one of the best
players of all time and just like keeps
himself in phenomenal Fitness and shape
and tries as hard as he can every single
year what do you have a problem with and
in the same way I feel like the same
that's happened for Zuck where it's like
so this guy who built this company that
billions of people use stuck with the
company he's he works hard every single
day
um you know married uh you know his
college sweetheart uh never been in
trouble with anything doesn't tweet out
offensive stuff doesn't say anything
just to get a reaction uh seems like a
perfectly reasonable guy works out hard
is a good dad like what do you hate
about this guy again what's going on do
you know how old Zuck is I don't know
he's like our age he's like he's a
little older than us right he's like 37
38 39. yeah he's he just turned 39 you
know in Lebron also 38. these guys are
the same man they're the same they've
been dude they were 18 yeah yeah LeBron
got drafted what he was a high schooler
right at high school Zach has been the
man since he was 21 or 22. there's been
nothing I mean there's been like if you
look the grand scheme it's there's been
no like human uh errors no no no no self
yeah there's been like business heirs
that have been cringed but there's been
nothing that they've done where you're
like oh that guy's a piece of [__]
because crime is cringe you're doing all
right yes when you're the man for that
long that is impossible that is so
challenging to do that uh you know what
I mean so we're clearly Zuck Fanboys
let's talk about threads though um oh
and by the way did you see what Elon
posted I don't know did you see it on
Twitter he goes Zuck is a [__] you know
what a [__] is yeah yeah uh I had to
look it up actually a cuck is a guy who
wants his wife to sleep with other men
and he like enjoys it uh and then he
also goes I challenge Zuck to a dick
measuring contest literally a dick
measuring contest like he says stuff
like that and I'm dude he says stuff
like that I'm like oh my God you're he's
an absolute tryhard to me uh don't don't
like it it says uh whether there's a
footy tweet from um Parker I think it's
Parker Thompson on Twitter he he replied
to that he goes okay so for those keep
it score at home Elon Elon brought a
bought a product for 44 billion and then
Zuck built the same product for a
thousand times less is stealing all of
his users like an absolute Chad it is
God willing about to choke them out in
90 seconds on steel cage soon huh so
that's what a cuff means now
[Laughter]
that's great man Zuck is just looking
great on this all right so by threads
you have on here that they grew to 70
million it's actually 100. it's a
hundred so they grew to 100 million
users in a week so we'll deliver the
bull case first so the bull case is this
uh will and the will threads win
um argument so the bull case is we're
five days in and they've reached 100
million users making it the fastest
growing product of all time okay
um Instagram has about a billion and a
half users they seem to be converting
over pretty quickly to this we already
got 100 million on the platform if 20 of
Instagram's users come on board it's now
bigger than Twitter so 20 conversion
from from Instagram is what they're
going to need they've done you know I
don't know five percent or something
like that I don't know public math
something like five percent so far in
five days
um the next reason that this is bullish
is Instagram and shared that on threads
he said um he goes he said we just hit
100 million and he said we've not even
really promoted it yet yeah we haven't
even done our promotions yet which is
yes nice it's also really cool that he's
revealing some of the stuff yeah yeah
he's really active on it right now he's
part Victory lap part like Community
engagement which is which is cool
um and he tweeted for the first time in
like 15 years right on the daily launch
which was which was also nice and it was
like the meme of the three Spidermans
pointing at it it was pretty it was
great he you know he's in on the gym
whoever he hired like his nephew or
whoever like just is like yo give me
their give me your app give me your
phone I'm Gonna Make You likable
um like hey instead of like fighting it
just post a meme it's cool don't worry
but he needs a verb so there's no verd
what do you say you threaded it you you
posted it yeah you know what I mean yeah
we're threading I don't know what's
going on so
the the interesting part is I'll go on
threads and I expect to see the same
sorts of people on as I do on Twitter
and there's some but there's a whole new
market of people who were basically
never on Twitter just didn't like
Twitter didn't work for them and so
um
so you know you get a whole new set of
people that are going to use threads
that weren't they don't have to switch
off of Twitter they're just new people
to a Twitter like Behavior so it can
basically beat Twitter without getting
people to switch because it's expanding
the market Twitter is I don't know if
you know this Twitter is basically the
most abandoned product
I think ever
so more than a billion people have
signed up for Twitter or tried Twitter
and they've been like
no I don't get it I'm good
just yeah that's not for me another the
big question the like sort of like the
100 billion dollar 200 billion dollar
question is
is that because the idea of Twitter
doesn't appeal to that many people or
that Twitter's execution was not good
enough to hook those people and if it's
the idea then those same people who try
threads will eventually bounce because
they're like they're just people who
like to look at pictures and videos they
don't want to write text and read random
ass text messages from different people
so if it's the idea that Twitter's safe
all these people will try it and they'll
bounce
but if it was the execution if it was
that Twitter didn't hook them properly
then they're screwed because if there's
one thing that that the Instagram and
Facebook teams are going to do well is
they're going to execute you can already
see it in the small things that they're
doing where they're like yeah we're just
gonna make like kind of like the feed
work better and blocking and muting and
like all of the like all of the stuff
we're just gonna do the stuff good the
stuff that they've been doing for 20
years which is like hey when somebody
signs up let's just make it really easy
for them to find like their friends or
interesting people for them and like
let's just make this this feed killer
like this would make this algorithm
killer where you just want to keep
scrolling stuff that Twitter never
really did like if you go look at
Twitter's ad product like have you ever
run Twitter ads yeah so this is what I
was gonna say this is another uh bull
case which is if you if if you've never
run ads before and you go talk to anyone
who has run any ads Facebook is always
in the top two or three parts of the
conversation so normally it's number one
it's usually the best platform I've
spent maybe 10 plus million dollars of
my own uh like me actually running ads
Facebook is always number one Twitter is
never part of the conversation I don't
know if I don't even know if it's any I
don't know if it's like that anymore
because I haven't run ads I run ads on
it now so I'm running ads on it
literally right now and uh it works but
the ad platform is so
trash compared to Facebook and Google's
ad platform
which is so surprising because that's
how they make money you would think
they're highly incentivized to do it so
anyways I guess my my bigger point is
not really about whose ad platform's
gonna be better it's just but that
matters it's going to be execution on
all the details on getting people linked
up with the right people making the feed
super interesting and you know and
handling spam better and abuse better
and all the things that Twitter has
struggled with over
over the years so the poll case is
basically this 100 million users if they
convert some of Instagram people they'll
be bigger than Twitter they don't even
need people from Twitter to switch they
can just bring net new people to the
market and that um and they can just
continue to promote this across
Instagram and WhatsApp so that's the
Bold case
um now I'm going to switch to the to the
bear case oh also part of the bull case
Twitter shoots itself in the foot a lot
so Elon does a lot of dumb [__] pisses a
lot of people off they um he's basically
pushing to like basically put a paywall
where like you have to pay eight dollars
a month in order to like have your [__]
be seen in the in the feed so that's
basically introducing friction he added
the Tweet limit not long ago which
introduces friction because oh you know
she's insane no more tweets for you uh
cut off like the ability to post tweets
and have them in bed in other places
because he was like oh we're getting
scraped too much so you basically put a
login wall in front of the content like
he's adding friction everywhere so these
are these are footfalls these are you
know nobody this is not threads killing
you this is you killing you and so
that's that's part of the bookcase now
here's the bear case
why this won't work
if I was to argue why this won't work
here's what I would say I'd say um
hey made the last Facebook Standalone
product that just worked not one that
they bought the one that they made
and that's where there's really a kind
of a graveyard of poke and a bunch of
these other apps that they tried to
create they tried to create a tick tock
competitor it didn't work they're trying
to create a Snapchat competitor it
didn't work so there is a graveyard of
these things the only things that have
worked up and things that they put into
the Instagram app like stories and reels
um because people are hooked on
Instagram so the Standalone app thing
hasn't really worked and this is a
standalone app
the next problem just because 100
million people try it doesn't mean
they're actually going to stick there's
going to be massive churn just like
there is have you gone back yeah I I
open it up right now but like I'm not
like hooked on it uh completely myself
yet are you
I'm not hooked yet no I'm definitely not
okay on Twitter but I've also built up
like
a big following plus a bunch of people
that I follow so my feed is more
interesting on Twitter yeah I was
curated for 10 years I was gonna say we
might be the one percent the one per
percent because we make a living in part
because of Twitter and so we could be
like there could be a part of it of like
ah [__] I don't want to use this other
thing because I already have this one
thing that's working and this thing is
just kind of like cannibalize it so I
can't tell if there's that bias there or
or what it is but no I'm not hooked yet
but I am opening it uh maybe once a day
maybe once every two days I am a little
bit like [__] I don't want another thing
to have to use uh but I am happy that
it's text based because that's where I
excel because you know I'm a Missouri
six but uh like
nine yeah I don't want I'm not like I'm
not I don't I got the I got a good face
for Twitter uh so like I prefer that but
yeah we we're the outliers because both
of us have I know the other we probably
have almost almost a million followers
together on on Twitter and so going now
I go to try I have three thousand
followers or something I'm starting from
scratch again and you know I'm like that
guy who I've moved to San Francisco
and I bought a house and I just redid my
lawn
and then everybody started moving and
they started raising the prices and I'm
like I'm I'm dug in I'm like yeah I'm
Duggan I already paid for the Renault uh
you know like I guess I'm just here what
everyone else is is choosing places that
might be a better fit so you know we we
might be the wrong person there
here's the other reasons that Twitter
might win
Twitter after the churn uh you know
threads might have 20 million or 30
million uh active users compared to
Twitter's 300 million right so I think
there's gonna be so much churn that this
100 million number is a bit of Fool's
Gold the next thing
Twitter has key content so it has news
it has Sports so it's got the journalist
it's got the athletes it's got the the
people that cover the NBA in the NFL
like it's got famous people it's Casey
got like this key like rapid breaking
news and influential content
um threads is gonna have new content but
like the type of person who's big on IG
may not be the right type of person for
what works in this text Medium we don't
TBD there's a TBD on that the next thing
threads is just a straight up clone
there are no product improvements and in
fact there's some big drawbacks like
they don't have DMS they don't have like
you know uh dude I get DMS I've been
getting DMs I think I don't know what
they're called there's no inbox
people have been messaging me let me
pull it up but I think they're at
mentioning you there's there's
definitely no no maybe that's what it is
I don't even know how to use it yet then
yeah it's it's a it's a mention but it
looks like a DM like the the thing looks
like a DM all right yeah you're right so
it's just they cloned the app but they
left some things out now that might that
might make it better but uh for the most
part I would say the product strategy
like if you've printed out the road map
so I hear some features and you turn the
page and it just says not Elon Musk not
Twitter right like it's just basically
here's not Twitter and like there's a
bunch of people who don't like Elon
don't like Twitter and they'll just try
this out so I don't know if that's a
great long-term product strategy
um by the way speaking of mediums and
leaving things out do you use Twitter on
your phone or desktop both yeah
I mostly use it on desktop and I use the
thread app and I was like Hey when's
when I need a desktop thing and that's
why I prefer typing on it and people
were like call me Boomer and [__] and
apparently that is that's some Boomer
[__] dude that's some Boomer [__] I
guess but I hate using it on my phone I
want to use it on my computer so I could
scroll through and click [__] yeah
that's like if a guy knocks on the
bathroom stalls like hey I gotta take a
piss sitting down and you're like what
it's not illegal to do what you're
saying but
certainly not acceptable and that's yeah
you're more of a what are you more of a
P with your shorts down at your ankle
type of guy while standing up
so so your your desktop thing yeah it's
okay to use desktop but let's not let's
not get out of control I think most I
not most I think a ton of people do that
man I'm telling you the older guys I
guess I'm old now but I need it
I I need it that's who we should appeal
to as a social media platform the older
guys
um yeah we'll call it khaki all right so
here's here's a couple other things
which is uh the best creators on Twitter
so the people who have basically earned
a 10 15 year period proven that they're
really good at creating text-based
content now have a big following and
don't really want to start over from
scratch on on Instagram aka me yeah so
so I think those are some of the some of
the downsides of this
um but I do think you know once you take
into account the bull in the bear case
it's prediction time how do you think
that this plays out
well you have to let's do the
interesting nuggets really quick if it
doesn't work out Nikita our friend
Nikita who is worked at meta and did all
the social stuff what did he say
uh he was basically like you know this
thing's gonna be at 100 million users
soon and if it fails after that that
will sort of officially make it the
biggest fail in social app history at
that point
which I think I don't think that really
means anything to be honest I think the
truth is I think it's going to end up
closer to the Bowl than it is the bear I
think it will it will more work than it
does fail I don't think Elon would ever
sell Twitter out of like Pride reasons
but I think it will if it weren't run by
a billionaire I think it would
effectively put it out of business uh
for the ad ad purposes
um I think it's gonna I think it's gonna
work I don't know if it will overtake
but I think it's gonna work so good that
it's got a cannibalize Twitter and it's
they're going to be at least equal
the CEO of cloudflare tweeted out a
chart I don't know if you saw this of
Twitter traffic because cloudflare has
like Canada they run like
that's [__] up right in some way
um it's yeah I don't know I don't know
maybe they haven't paid their bill or
maybe there's like a doctor that's like
a doctor like revealing like your
illnesses isn't it it's like it's like
these two guys are making fun of each
other it's like actually this guy his
cholesterol is way worse than yours
right yeah so like if you want to beat
them up but kick them in the left knee
[Laughter]
yeah he did that basically he tweeted
out showing that this uh that Twitter's
down like five percent in overall
traffic so far this week
um from from thread so it's like you
know he said like it's uh plummeting or
something like that like dropping off a
cliff which is like pretty dramatic for
I don't know five percent I wouldn't
call plummeting but um
that's weird that he shared that that's
super weird yeah uh yeah I I I I it's
going to be closer to the bowl I and
whatever I've learned Nikita actually
would always joke about this he would
say never ever ever bet against Zuck and
I've heard so many people say that when
I bet against Elon for sure uh not often
not often I think that he follows
through a lot he's just been closer to
death so many times and I don't think
Zuck entirely has uh I just think that
Zuckerberg when it comes to this field a
consumer social I just think that he's I
would not bet against that person yeah
exactly I think that's the that's the
rub here I think that
um
it's not Zuck versus Elon mono imano
like they are like in the same way that
in the cage Zuck will probably win
because he trains he's been training Jiu
Jitsu for like you know a couple years
so that's it gives him a little Head
Start
um
in the same way that Zuck probably could
not build a rocket company or a car
company you're playing you can even
build Oculus like he couldn't even like
do that everywhere it's doing pretty
well to be honest
um it's doing okay but I think that
they're gonna miss they're not gonna be
like the one
perhaps we'll see but I guess like it's
his domain so the social app thing is is
their domain they have Instagram I think
I'm with you I land where I do think
threads will be bigger than Twitter I
don't think it kills Twitter
I just think it sort of stunts whatever
slow growth that Twitter has it just
stunts it even further and Twitter
remains this kind of niche
this basically this thing that has
really strong appeal to a niche and I
think that threads becomes the more
mainstream version of it like I think it
becomes the more palatable
just cool interesting thing in the same
in the same way that like this happens a
lot with music or with uh TV shows or
with with stuff like that where
something has its time and then the new
thing comes out
and it's just has like a little more
mainstream appeal and it just becomes
the default and the other thing does it
die doesn't go away necessarily but um
but I do think that if you fast forward
two years or 18 to 24 months
I think it's pretty I think my bet would
be threads is bigger than Twitter and
Twitter basically has now like a ceiling
on its head that is bumping into it can
never really grow from there it might
get better at monetizing those people or
preventing them from switching
but the dominant place for that will be
will be threads which is insane to me it
seemed impossible like to Dethrone a
social network
like 12 months ago there's this cultural
shift with young people where there's so
much more kind and nicer than our
generation when we were that age
and
you see that in Tick Tock so if you go
to tick tock and you look at the
comments people are so much more
positive uh there's still something
they're not more positive that's Tick
Tock is amazing at sorted comments and
hiding comments whatever whatever that
is okay maybe maybe because all you
build is kindness and jokes and then
you're like Ah that's how I'm supposed
to behave here and Twitter right it
builds a culture whereas on Twitter I
post something and I get made fun of so
much sometimes and I always click on the
accounts and it's clearly like a bot or
I don't know what it is but there's this
huge underground culture I have no idea
how this is happening of people who all
they do is make fun of make fun of
people and I always it shows it to me do
you get that when people are making fun
of you all the time yeah
yeah it just shows you everything
Twitter says it shows you everything you
said something here's what they said
back and guess what there's always going
to be people that either disagree argue
or just say mean [__] to you that's like
you know just that's actually the way
the world works
the best companies have figured out how
how to algorithmically like suppress
that behavior yes and when the day I
opened up threads it was like garyvee
saying like I hope you all have such a
wonderful day and it was like they like
seeded it with like these positive
people and it like created this weird
culture where it seems significantly
more positive so if you open up threads
like good morning y'all yeah
I have like pomp saying like I hope you
have a wonderful day and get after it uh
like it's just so much and I have sahil
already popping up on my [__] it's like
all positivity whereas Twitter it's way
more negative and honestly it does wear
me out and by the way Zuck has sort of
said this in his in his threads where
he's like uh yeah that's part of our key
strategy he's like he's like I always
thought there should be a a sort of like
this town square conversation public
conversation type product that gets to a
billion users
Twitter for some reason never figured it
out we're gonna do our best and then
people are like you know uh oh I noticed
this place is like you know more kind or
sort of like you know much more positive
energy right now and he goes yeah I
think that's really important
um that's what we're gonna you know
that's something we're gonna really
focus on and try to get right I don't
think that Twitter ever got that right
and um some of these features like
setting the culture in that way are
invisible they're not like
now you can do live video now you could
use Twitter spaces it's not a feature
that you see it's almost what you don't
see that's the feature and I think that
Facebook and Instagram have a lot of
experience fighting abuse spam hateful
content and it's not gonna be nowhere
it's not it's going to be gone like that
whatever that's fine I get that but I
think they're going to do a better job
of it in the same way that like you
remember
it used to be a common thing people say
which is like if you ever want to see
sort of Hell on Earth go to the YouTube
comments like YouTube comments were
considered like an actual cesspool
and now if you go to a popular YouTube
video
the comments are often like they add to
the joke they're funny and they're
positive
and I don't know what they did over time
but over time they fixed that problem
which was that the YouTube comments were
like you know where you know hope goes
to die and now uh it's good it's part of
the experience I'm sure there's some
spam or there's still obviously like the
one-off thing but it's nowhere near
where it was like in the early days
I went out to dinner last night I'm uh
in Williamsburg I went out to dinner
last night and I you know Williamsburg
everything's tight in New York and I sat
next to this guy who worked at meta on
the threads team and
I'm not going to reveal a lot because I
don't want to write this guy out but me
and Sarah were out to dinner and like I
texted her I was like just let's just
not talk and we just listened to this
guy we just listened to this guy talk
for two hours about launch week and like
what it was like and he was like it was
the most exciting time of my career this
guy was so bought in to like the threads
movement he even was talking about how
much money he was making it was crazy
man I was just a dish what'd you hear
you don't have to say the person but
tell us everything it was it was seven
figures a year it was seven figures this
guy and like I feel like I know all
about this guy kind of know where he's
from
um or at least I know where he moved
from I heard the very the very typical
this is so funny you hear people say
it's all the time when they first moved
to New York or when they're like Tech
guys they say uh San Francisco was all
about what have you built lately New
York it's all about how much money do
you make you know you're reminded every
time about how important money is San
Francisco it's all about what you build
like that's like such are you saying it
in a positive way
it's refreshing that my pay stub
delivers
uh but he was just talking about like he
was like the launch and he was just
saying like how the morale the company
is really high and how everyone was
pumped which is which is something
Facebook needed because it was pretty
shitty for a long time with all the
negative PR
um and he was just talking all about
like the launch and like what they were
doing it was so fascinating it would
just sit there I'm shocked that he
didn't like catch the hit that I was
just like listening to this old
conversation I just heard everything hey
if there's one thing uh that Facebook
Engineers don't have a lot of awareness
dude I don't think you noticed that you
weren't talking to your wife
you ever um go out to dinner and like if
you're with like a business associate or
like a successful friend and you talk
about money uh you're talking about like
you know like I want to buy this house
it costs as much money or like this is
what I'm earning what do you think I
should do with it whatever we talk about
these sensitive topics whenever the
waitress or waiter comes over I always
quit talking about that because I'm like
that's embarrassing it's tacky
they didn't get that hit and so I
remember them talking about I remember
them they they said the seven figure
thing it's like yeah it's not that big
of a deal you just go get like a
director or a startup and get a you know
a million dollar package and that's okay
but like are you really doing anything
meaningful right as the woman was like
waiting to see if they wanted dessert
yeah and I remember seeing that I was
like oh I hate that that is so [__]
embarrassing and obnoxious you gotta
shut up at that point that's when you
you know you're like you got to lower
your voice you gotta whisper a million
you know what I mean like that that's
what you're supposed to do in that
scenario but these guys did not catch
that hit I hate that yeah yeah
there's a little PC that dies inside
every time you know who sucks at that is
whenever I'm with our friends Suli Suli
is horrible at that is we talk about
[__] yes we'll talk about like you know
about like what he's investing in so
loudly and I'm like dude shut the [__]
up this is embarrassing everyone's
looking over you don't don't use that
word million please I don't have any
more of those conversations I haven't
seen that um but I've I have another
friend that does it like crazy and then
I'll be like hey I'm like kicking them
under the table and he'll just be like
what why are you kicking me I'm like
dude
I'm a friend that we took to this place
um in San Francisco that I guess has
like the best hot chocolate if he likes
Hot Chocolate so we're like dude you're
a little baby for liking hot chocolate
first of all but if you are a baby that
likes Hot Chocolate you got to go to
this place has the best hot chocolate so
we go sits at the bar bartender comes up
or whatever like the table whatever and
it's like hey uh this guy loves hot
chocolate and we told him this is the
best spot so he had to he had to try it
and he's like the waiter was like what
are you for yeah he's like oh cool yeah
yeah let me bring you one so he brings
one out
that takes a step uh immediately gives
like an audible like Ugh
what and then it doesn't like it and so
we're like oh you know whatever okay
guess it's not I don't know
guess not your your way uh your your
type and so he just puts he just he puts
it down right so it's sitting in front
of him
uh waiter walks by
and he just sh like pushes it forward
towards the uh almost like he's pushing
his chips all in at like a poker table
and the guy's like oh are you are you
done and he's like you didn't like it he
goes no it's not very good oh my God
that's so embarrassing accomplish here
why are you doing this so I literally
just fall off my stool and crawl away
and die and uh you know that had to deal
with this interaction but it was
terrible I had a friend we went out and
got dinner and afterwards they gave us
coffee and we wanted decaf and the next
day we texted back and forth we're like
hey did you stay up all night last night
and they were like yeah I was like I
think they gave us regular coffee he's
like I gotta call them I gotta call them
and let them know and he was like
insistent like he's like I gotta call
them and so we like call them I'm like
dude what what's what are you doing
we're on vacation like we're visiting
like what that's such a weird it was
such a Larry David move to like call
someone to tell them you made a mistake
last night you gave us a normal coffee
instead of decaf and I those types of
people are very challenging for me
it's like uh likable and adorable and uh
when anybody else in real life does it
it's just hateable my my mother-in-law
has a version of that where anytime
we're complaining about something her
go-to is not even like tell them and
call them she's like call the news
channel five they they will investigate
this it's really nice dude I can't stand
that it's really not what's gonna happen
here I've ordered a steak before and
they've brought me pesto chicken pizza
and I won't say a word I'm like
so this is um
this is I can't decide I wanted to do a
segment called L of the week because I
think we sometimes brag a lot on here if
we say you know how we're so great and
all these boys I think it'd be nice to
share a big L that we took
but I got to be honest this might
actually be a dub this might not even be
an L because the experience was so
important all right so I go I'm feeling
I'm doing something I'm working whatever
and I'm feeling hungry while I was
driving back from an errand and I'm like
I'm hungry I'm just gonna pick up some
food real quick so I go to uh Subway
and I'll get a sandwich
and uh I go to Subway I walk in there's
like five people in line there's only
one guy working and it's a black guy and
there's a white guy checking out and
I'm like thinking about what sandwich
I'm gonna get and I kind of decide
I noticed that that guy's still checking
out and I look over and I'm like what's
taking this guy forever and these guys
are talking about like it's like so
we're South Africa he's like yeah
they're talking about Africa and talking
about race it's about race relations and
they're just talking and like zero
like I'm happy that there's whatever no
racism on Earth but I'd really like a
sandwich right now and so with the four
people about that meatball marinara yeah
exactly yeah red that's the color of my
meatball that I like right now um and so
they're just talking and then they
[__] they hug and I'm like what's
going on right now and when they hug I
lose it I leave I walk out and I'm like
I'm hungrier than ever because I've just
killed nine minutes here
exclusively about a sandwich and I got
teased there's no sandwich coming
right next to the subway is a Taco Bell
and I make a business decision I say it
is I guess it is what it is I'm going to
Taco Bell today I haven't been to Taco
Bell like 13 years going to Taco Bell so
I walk into Taco Bell and I'm in line
I'm and you could always I have this
theory about places which is
you could see your future when you go
into a place because it's you're gonna
end up if you go to a place regularly
enough you're gonna start looking like
the people that that are in that place
so sometimes I'll go to a like a fitness
class and I'll look around and be like
all right if people who are like the
clear regulars here don't look the way I
want to look
I'm just gonna leave now because this is
this is not a good path right it's like
a good life yeah would you what you see
and talk about like a bunch of like
Tweety Bird shirts so I go to First
everybody to talk about was under 17. so
I was like oh I get it their body can
like still tolerate this I'm the only
guy in his 30s at this place so I'm I'm
and there's one guy sitting there and
he's probably like 28. and he's sitting
down and it's just him and he's got a
feast in front of him like this guy he
was like Hey Omakase Chef's Choice bring
it all out so he's Omakase that Taco
Bell and he's sitting there he's eating
up a storm and there's only me these
three teen girls who are in front of me
ordering and then this guy
it is kind of quiet in Taco Bell
as I'm standing in line and this guy
pulls a move that I I I'm still stunned
just thinking about this
he's sitting there in Taco Bell eating
his feast
and he just rips the loudest fart
and we all look over
I'm like wow so embarrassing this guy
just farted aloud in public wow it was
almost like he's sitting on one of those
benches it like echoed it was like this
crazy auditory experience and I look at
the guy and he just stares back at all
of us and he's just raised his eyebrows
like what we're all here like you're
also here at 3 P.M on a Tuesday and that
is what it is
this guy did not back down he didn't
have an hour and shame he outfit us and
was just he literally was like what
and I was like nothing I guess just
carry on
you're right we're all equals here
you just got Dutch oven by a Taco Bell
guy
it was like a l I took and a big dough
for this guy but I just it's an
experience
when did that happen this is like five
days ago I've been sitting on the store
there's no one else I could really tell
like uh I started to tell the story to
my wife and she was like you went to
Taco Bell and I was like you're missing
the point of the whole story and I
didn't even get to the good part and I
just thought you should have farted back
at him I wish I had one in the chamber I
didn't I mean he really just like laid
it down right there in front of us and
what did the girl say the eye contact
nobody said anything we all look to
laugh at him and then we just got
stunned by his bravado
holy [__] this is the biggest power
moment I've ever experienced
that's the past how was the food at
least
horrible honestly the food to talk about
is phenomenal uh like the taste of Taco
Bell
is great it is a great taste they got
like
the menu I mean first of all the
Innovation you've been to a Taco Bell
like you know Taco Bell used to be tacos
it's not like
it's like this dude it's just the same
[__] Doritos let's become a taco now
it's a taco inside of a burrito and it's
like how's the taco inside the burrito
and you're like that's we call it a
Cheesy Gordita Crunch and then they had
like this thing called the volcano right
now and I was like I guess just give me
the volcano because I didn't even know
what to do there I was like I don't
really understand what's happening I'm
Still Still reeling from what just
happened a few minutes ago and I I got
the volcano thing it was great it was
fantastic you should have brought that
African guy over to get it let them
sniff up America let them see what this
is what we're about bro come on peace
love and happiness is that hug [__]
that's not what it is that's not the
usual experience this this is the reason
this is why this is the world war
back-to-back Champions because guys like
that salt of the earth they don't make
them like that like that anymore can you
imagine a European doing that impossible
no possible
no
from Singapore never you get arrested
for that ticket for it yeah yeah that's
like that's like five to twenty in
Singapore that's not a chance
foreign
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets
serve dueling databases HubSpot grow
better
so Sean I've got a funny story so we
have Sam Evans today I'll do a little
bit of an intro but about
three or four years ago I used to see
Sam's ads everywhere and it was
basically him in a bright blue blazer in
his fancy apartment overlooking
Manhattan
and there was a little bit of hate in me
and there was a little bit of uh you had
slick back hair too I remember he had
slick black hair yeah and for some
reason he pissed me off and I wrote like
on one of the ads like you're full of
[__] or something like that
you did a hater comment
I did a hater comment and it's sat it'd
be for years and I talked to my friends
who eventually bought some of his
products and they're like oh no it's
awesome we loved it and I started
learning more and I was like I think I
was wrong and so I sent Sam this message
I think 18 or 24 months ago and I was
like I'm sorry that was for some reason
that one comment it bothered me and
eventually I saw Sam four weeks ago at a
party at Sophia's party and I talked to
him and my wife and I talked to him for
like an hour and I was like
you're you're one of the more
fascinating people that I've ever spoke
to and I was like did you get that email
where I apologize I said I got it so
that's kind of like how we got here but
Sam what um
how do you describe yourself you had
consulting.com which was like a big
information business but you have a new
thing uh you want to you want to tell us
uh how you described yourself
sure
um
well I'm an entrepreneur
um and
I have a software company called school
I'm CEO of that and it's it's like a
community platform for creators you're
you're kind of understanding yourself
there eh
what do you want me to say
the reason why I like to get out with
you is Sean he reminds me of Jack Smith
so much like it's the same type of like
yeah the funny thing is like Jack
um you're right uh there's like
definitely like a uh an echo of Jack
there but Jax I almost feel like Jack
picked business models that suited his
uh like personality and his like way of
thinking
um whereas Sam the funny thing is that
when I discovered you like Sam I saw
um this sort of like
uh outgoing persona it's like guy who's
you know recording a selfie video of
himself in his fancy apartment telling
me something it's sort of like oh this
guy thinks he's some hot shot business
guy whatever
and now you talk now and I'm like this
guy owns a surf shop or something why is
this guy like in the like the most zen
zen mode almost introverted to an extent
um
isn't that strange was that strange for
you to have like a very public Persona
even though you clearly are actually
more of a of a of a laid-back maybe more
introverted guy
yeah I think that's why it
robbed people the wrong way like Sam
um because
you know that's kind of the thing that I
didn't like about that business like if
you're selling training or coaching or
whatever it's you have to be very out
there you have to make content of
yourself you have to
you have to continuously promote
yourself right and I was always very
uncomfortable doing that
um
and I guess I I used like the New York
apartment and the blue suit is like a
character yeah like a character or like
a crutch to help me you know what I mean
yeah and it worked you built
consulting.com which was like a the way
I'll describe it was like sort of like
training masterminds courses type of
thing where you would teach people how
to start their own Consulting business
and people pay a few thousand dollars
and you you put a bunch of free content
and that would get people sort of in the
funnel and then eventually they would
pay you a couple thousand dollars to
learn how to start their own Consulting
business and uh from what I understand
like you scaled it up to uh about 30
million a year at one point out of sort
of the peak on on the revenue side
um before being like this is too much
and too crazy and we have too many
people two little profits we're pushing
like you know the boundary too much you
sort of scaled it back down
um to a more manageable level where the
revenue went down but the profits went
you know up or the same
um and you had less headache so it
definitely worked did you get where'd
you get the idea for that were you just
like in a basement watching Tai Lopez
videos being like okay I understand I
could do this now or like where why did
you decide to even do that you mean like
sell courses sell courses in the way
that you sold them which was just like a
really heavy uh paid ad strategy with
you as this character or this Persona
the face of it very internet marketing
yeah
well
um I wanna
to start my own business I used to have
a job this is going back like 12 years
um and I used to watch this
this interview site called mixergy do
you guys remember that yeah yeah we love
Andrew yeah
um and I watched an interview one day
and this guy was saying that he was
gonna show he had a software company his
name was Dane Maxwell
and then he said he was going to teach
some other people how to start a
software company and that was my first
experience of being in a course he
launched a course that was called back
then the software Round Table
and I learned how to start a software
company
in that and started a software company
it was called Snap and spec
and so I first experienced being in a
course
like from the student side
and
through that experience I
I had a successful software company and
then I was like the star student of that
of that
software Roundtable Foundation thing
um so then I did and he made me do an
interview on mixergy this is back when I
was very young and then a bunch of
people started emailing me and saying
could I they wanted to pay me so I could
help them with their software company
and I would just sell like six one-hour
Skype calls for one thousand dollars
and
then very quickly I ran out of time to
sell
like I sold so many of these packages
and I just noticed that I was repeating
myself on these calls like a lot
and I was like oh this this could be a
course everyone's like struggling with
the same problems
and so
and I've run out of time right so the
next guy I took through this six one
hour course I recorded the calls and
then I put them in a Dropbox folder
and then the people that wanted to buy
my coaching and from that point on I
said I don't have any time left but I've
got like a course that you can buy for
the same price
and I would just sell it for one
thousand dollars and give them a login
to the Dropbox
and they would watch the recordings in
there and they liked it and they
they didn't ask for their money back and
just like
and that's where it started and then
when I sold more and more of those I was
like whoa this is
I should put some more effort into this
so I did and then I
and then I wondered well how can I sell
more of this instead of just waiting for
people to come to me
from my mixergy interview and ask me
over email
so that's when I started learning about
like internet marketing
um
and then I remember the people back then
were like Frank Kern and
who else there was like ramit Sethi
there was
this guy called clay Collins do you
remember this era of like yeah
and so I just kind of got
I learned how to Market from that world
like that kind of underground internet
marketing world
and that's
and then my course business started to
do so good it quickly overtook the the
profit of my software company
and I just wasn't very passionate about
property management which was the niche
that my software product was for was
that called Snap inspect yeah it still
exists it's snapinspec.com and I just
wasn't passionate about the niche
um so I sold my shares of snap inspect
to my co-founder
and then just went all in on the course
business and that's what eventually
became consulting.com
and in the end I was making courses
showing people how to make courses I
just fell in love with the craft of
like finding a group of people
that you care about
and solving their problems
and then sharing the solutions with them
and turning that into a business how did
you get the domain consulting.com
because that's a great domain
um it was I went to The Domain I went to
the URL and it was there was nothing on
it and then I used like MX toolbox to
find out like who owned it
and then I just sent him an email and I
said you want to sell it and he said yes
how much you pay for that one
um that one was three hundred thousand
just um just in the the 10 minutes that
you've just given that Spiel and tell
them the background and then the hour
that I've hung out with you you have
this trait that I love that certain
people have where in your brain I could
see you're the type of person that you
see a challenge and you don't think of
it like a lot of people think of it as
an emotional thing but it's a very
logical and you're like this is a puzzle
I'm gonna figure out this math equation
and that gives you Joy at least it seems
like it
um with the marketing thing it seems
like the same thing where you're like
well if I wear this jacket that will pop
off in a thumbnail and that's important
for a higher click-through rate and it's
like you just read tons of books and you
put together like an algorithm on what
to do and it's and that's why it it
didn't seem entirely authentic that that
was who you were but it seemed like you
were just playing a game that you wanted
to win is that how you went about it and
who did you what interesting people did
you learn the the the algorithm from
that aren't entirely popular or that are
like some strange resources
I guess you know there was I just looked
at the people who are doing quote well
like and Brenda bashard
and
Marie forleo this is back then
um
and I knew I noticed that they had like
a a
if you thought of their name you could
quickly assign like a couple of
attributes to them they had like a brand
essentially
and I was like this kid from New Zealand
teaching people how to start a business
and so I was like
whatever it is it needs to if when
people see my video they instantly need
to think of money basically
and my main Market is New York I mean my
main Market is America and New York is
like
so iconic and it means it's like the
money place right so
that was why I went to New York and why
I found an apartment with a view like
that I heard a rumor that that apartment
is almost like exactly the same
apartment as something from it was it a
Wolf of Wall Street or one of those like
iconic money movies where they like hang
a guy over the balcony I heard that that
you wanted that apartment for that
reason is that true that isn't true
um I wanted the apartment because it had
a really cool View
but then we were watching that movie and
we had to pause it and be like wait a
second is that this building and we
realized it's not the same building but
it must be one of the five in that area
that are all very close to each other
got it
and so you
um you start doing this now I'm curious
a lot of the names you mentioned I never
hear about those people anymore uh you
know I've I remember Frank Kearns I
remember uh even Pagan and some of these
guys that you know you could kind of go
study their their content their funnels
um but they're not around anymore or if
they are like I don't know where they
are they're not they don't seem to be
like
crushing it anymore like they used to
um Am I Wrong are they just out there
crushing and I just don't see them for
some reason or why do you think that
they very few kind of sustained or did
they just get so rich they quit or are
they like locked into one mode and they
didn't evolve at the Times what do you
think happened I think things have
changed a lot and a lot of people didn't
adapt
but also I think some people just got
like
they're just not going as hard or they
might have got burned out and they're
just relaxing a little bit
um it's probably a combination of all of
those things how how big were some of
those old school marketers well they're
all cool to me how big were some of
their businesses you never know like
that's why it's always so interesting I
I I I had no idea because they never
told me they seemed to they weren't real
businesses in a way because they would
make a a ton of money on a launch right
but then that product would kind of go
away and then they might do another
launch in six months and it was all
based on this launch model and these
launches would pull big numbers like
millions of dollars but and I'm sure
there was a lot of profit in that too
but they weren't like
these products that were Evergreen that
could be sold continuously and they
didn't have a team and they weren't like
contributing to this body of work they
weren't building on top of what they
built yesterday essentially you had this
interesting video where
yeah there we were talking about Jack
Jack's one of my best buddies and he was
on the last episode and you guys are
very similar but on this video you
opened it up and you just looked at the
camera and you go I'm back and
apparently like the story of the video
was consulting.com Consulting got got to
like 30 million in revenue and you would
hire dozens of people fancy offices you
hated it you basically scale it down I
think you called it a band I think it
was like five or six people you were
like we're gonna do 10 million in
Revenue 5 million in profit everyone
gets a share of the profit what uh what
was like the peak of the Consulting
business and then where was it when you
sold it
sure so the peak was
it must have been around like two
thousand and
17 or 2018
and
it was doing 36 million a year in
Revenue
um but profit-wise was probably only
like 5 million on there most of it was
was um expenses and we had about 50
people and we were spending like 2
million a month on ads
um and it was just everything was
breaking I hired everyone way too fast
and
it was heavily dependent on ads
um which I didn't like I was reading
this book on my honeymoon in um toulomb
in Mexico
and
it's called
um lean thinking
and apparently it's like Jeff bezos's
favorite book which is why I was reading
it
and in there they talk about like
how you should optimize a business
based on customer based on value the way
a customer experiences it right and you
should analyze like the head count how
many people are like working on
how many people are actually
contributing to Value the customer would
experience in your head count and then
your your money flows so like how are
you allocating the capital where is all
the money being spent and does the
customer experience value from that and
then your time and attention and energy
right so you're just analyzing all of
these flows
and I realized that
all of our time money attention and head
count was on ads
and that customers did not
think ads were valuable in fact they
thought what you did it actually pissed
them off right so I was like oh man I've
really screwed this one up
um
and I was like everything should be
focused on the customer and so I went
back
after that vacation and realized that I
basically had to
start again
and I so I just started
restructuring that company
um
I realized that organic content was
really good because that's customers
find that valuable right like a good
YouTube channel good email newsletter
so I was like we should do that and then
if we do that well we don't need to do
ads and then I was like everyone on the
team should be
contributing value to like the customer
they should be doing support or they
should be account management for
Mastermind clients they should be
customer facing in some way
and all of my time and attention and
energy should be thinking about the
customers problems instead of
advertising problems right
and so I just with that kind of mental
model I just started restructuring the
whole company and then so like you
you've talked about Consulting uh a
bunch on other pods and but the story is
that you eventually and we can go back
to you eventually sold it but your new
company school it's uh whenever I was
texting to you it always uh autocorrects
the stool s-k-o-o-l you were telling me
you didn't exactly say it this way but I
I read it this way you were telling me
that you you're like we're not taking
any funding or at least you're not
anytime soon because you self-funded it
with 10 million and you're like I'm
hiring the best people so you like went
from like this like internet marketing
type of culture to Startup first of all
is that true and second was that number
right 10 million that you're going in on
this that's true yeah
and why the shift from like this startup
where you like have hired all the like
you're you're running things very
Silicon Valley esque versus what I
imagine in my head a lot of uh
internet marketers are not like well I
started in software remember the first
company I ever did was snap inspect so
I've always had a love for software the
problem back then though was I didn't
love my market
like property managers
and I
we were constantly have limited by our
money like
you know software Engineers are
expensive subscription Revenue has a
cash flow trough in it
um
and so we were limited by money and I
didn't love my market but I did love
software and I also hated like having to
Market I swore I was never going to
touch software again unless it had
Network effects
because I wanted it to grow itself
basically like a platform instead of a
software tool
um so then I fell in love with courses
and that the beauty of that was like I
was able to save a lot of money
um
and then I came back to software because
I now was building software for the
market that I loved which was like
online creators
and I had money this time so I wouldn't
be limited by that I could get the best
engineers and not cut corners on
anything and take a more long-term View
um
and this was a platform opportunity
instead of like a software tool so we
didn't have to have a marketing or sales
team
um
and we had no like CAC
um and how is this growing because I see
the traffic is like I don't know eight
million visits a month or something
insane like that
um looks like you got an affiliate
program here if you're not running
marketing where's the growth coming from
because I get that there's Network
effects but um that's way more than like
Circle Doc is it called Circle that's
way more than a lot of like High VC
competitors the traffic I believe yeah
so I don't know if the number's right
but let's say it's more than double
circle yeah
um how are you getting so much traffic
it's a community platform so you know
once you
once you start a community and you add
some content to it the first thing you
do is you invite members right
and then what happens is roughly one
percent of members
create their own community
so they're like oh this platform's cool
I want to make one of these and then
they create their own and then they
invite their members and then that
there's a there's a loop there or a
network effect when you were doing your
content stuff
um your ads I had read stuff like you
um did some interesting things like you
we talked about like the apartment and
the suit and I don't know like a
motorcycle in the middle of the room and
stuff like that what were some
interesting experiments that you ran
that
um that either worked or didn't work
that sort of taught you something about
you know human psychology or the way
that people's
what gets people's attention what people
what gets people interested what gets
them hooked what are some learnings from
all those different kind of content
experiments you did when you were doing
uh when you're making you know when when
you're your content your face was the
was the driver
well a lot of people just want to make
money like that one was annoying so if
you just put a jet in something or a
fancy car or a New York apartment like
it works so well that it's
it's annoying because you're like oh do
I have to do that [__] aren't people
just won't they just listen to the value
of the idea but that's what I learned
back then when I was doing those
experiments I think now people are
looking for like longer form real stuff
that
like a podcast podcasts are really
taking off right
um
so I think the people that are doing a
good job now is like
what you guys are doing I think having a
podcast in an email newsletter that's
what I would do if I was starting again
right now
um that those two work really well
together we have this friend Rebecca
zamalo who um has tens of millions or
maybe 15 or something million YouTube
subscribers and she only launched it in
like 2017 not that long ago and I was
like Rebecca why did you get so big and
she goes I took it like a job so like I
got laid off or I quit I forget what
happened with her other job and she goes
this is now my thing so it was like a
40-hour work week it's like this is all
I'm doing and I was like well doesn't
everyone do that she said no shockingly
no most of a lot of popular YouTubers it
starts with a side Hobby and even when
they're like fairly big it's still not
full time but she's like I just treat
this sumbitch like a company like I just
ran it like a company and it worked out
so I think that like that Focus thing no
no chance he said some [__]
maybe
it was like
you know I took this wonderful thing
very seriously uh
yeah yeah you've been you've been pretty
good with Focus I mean that's why you've
been self-consulting.com if it's like
doing well and you're not working on it
I mean you're about you seem like you're
you're very very very focused on [__] I
mean just to go 10 million on that on
school is that a was that a significant
chunk for you to do that and was that
like a verbal commitment like I'm
willing to do up to X or did you
literally wire into a bank account so
that's now in the company that's being
used for this company it's we're burned
in that
that yeah that like I bought a house
because you know I've got a wife and
family so I've bought a house and I left
some money in the personal account for
like family and then I was like
everything else I'm just I'm betting on
this company so not no other portfolio
nothing how big do you think school's
gonna be
what that's hard to answer there's what
I would like it to be which is what
I've always wanted to build something
that a billion people use what are you
how are you sleeping at night knowing
that your whole or a lot of your nut is
in there
that's a very stressful thing
quite well at the moment but because
things are going really well
um
you know what the growth is compounding
pretty fast and
top tier VCS email us every week
so I like and they I've had to just stop
talking to them
um
and a lot of people want to give us
money but we're not taking it
and so I think the fact that a lot of
people want to give me money is
allowed me to calm down quite a lot that
I'm not that we're not going to run out
of money
um
also just the grow what is it profitable
no it's not
but deliberately so okay fair enough and
um where'd you base the company uh is it
remote or people in uh in America in New
Zealand where you where are your people
um everyone's in LA and San Fran okay
okay and do you um you like when we when
Sam says you remind him of Jack Smith
one of the cool things about Jack Smith
is that while he's clever and
interesting on the business side he's
also clever and weird and does crazy
experiments also in his personal life uh
whether it's like sort of biohacking or
uh lifestyle choice or not naming his
child until she was one years old like
whatever apparent parenting everything
he takes sort of like a novel approach
to each thing I'm curious
are you weird in other areas of your
life do you do anything that's sort of
non-standard that to you makes sense but
maybe to other people sounds a little
strange I'm sure would you like to say
any examples since this is a podcast
um
I mean I slipped on a futon for like
three years and I loved it and then when
my wife got pregnant she she made me
give it up but I really missed that
futon you know a Japanese futon yeah um
I love that thing
um I just like to keep things very
simple and minimal like I only have one
pair of shoes
and I only have like the same type of
socks and the same kind of like
underwear in the same t-shirts and then
like three wool jumpers
and that's all I have
and then I have the same soap like this
tea tree soap
and I just have like 20 blocks of it and
I I even take one with me when I travel
because I only like that so
um I like don't wear sunglasses because
I think they're unnecessary
um
and I just like to reduce things just to
I like to find something that I think is
good
and then only use that
and then just get a few different pairs
of that and just keep things as simple
and as minimal as humanly possible is
your wife normal
yeah she is
we were the reason why one of the things
you said
we were sitting around Sean it was me
saying my wife Sarah we are sitting
around at this restaurant
and Sam you have
you've got some strange energy in a very
cool way you've got very strange and
cool energy that I like I love people
like you
and we were just sitting around
and the conversation kind of died and we
were just we sat in silence for like
three seconds I think
and then you just said I delivered my
baby and we were like
we were like what with what because I
had my hands
we're like hold on say this again and
you're talking about how your wife she
you're going to be like a home delivery
or something and the Midwife didn't make
it in time and you just did the damn
thing and you just did it and I remember
thinking like
the reason I love this guy
is I don't think he understands
like how strength like your mannerisms
your voice they're this is they're so
unique and strange in such an
interesting way
um which I frankly love I love people
like you because you're so unique and
you're not vanilla do you realize that
you're like that
honestly not really
because I don't I don't try to fit in
and I don't try to like I don't even
look at what other people are doing like
I don't have social media at all
um and I never look at really what's
going on or what's in the news or
anything
and I just do what I want what do you do
with that free time so let's say no
social media no news for most people
that's like four to five hours a day or
something like that how do you reinvest
that four to five hours a day where do
you put it what what does give you
energy or what do you do for
entertainment or what do you do to to
unwind
I mean all I really do is
focus on school and that's mostly the
product so I'm just obsessive about the
product all the details of it and then
I go home hang out with my wife and
daughter
and then I need two hours
of like watching something to to unwind
otherwise I can't sleep
and so I'll I'll watch series
like TV series and I like old stuff like
things before technology because it's
it's nice and slow and it helps me go to
sleep but when you say you're obsessive
what does that mean like do people like
working with you like are you the type
of guy who like if something very small
at the footer is screwed up you freak
out over that
you know I can see a pixel
so if something's off like I'm like
something's off over there and then I'll
inspect it with chrome inspector and it
will be one pixel so I can like I I joke
with the team that I can see at pixel
um
and yeah I'll I'll go into those details
like I designed
schools interface and figma like the
whole thing
um and
defined a lot of like how that entire
system works which is it's quite complex
well I knew you were like that because
when consulting.com first came out
most courses don't didn't look the way
yours looked yours had this like you had
this really cool thing of a it was like
a caveman becoming a person uh right is
that what it was and then it was like a
picture of the globe and it uh it looked
like a software page it looked very
unique and I remember seeing the design
of it and I thought that is incredibly
unique and it stood out it made you feel
more sophisticated than most other
people in the space
um you remember that page it might
describing it I do accurately yeah what
uh what were you think when you made
that well that's what I like to do I
like to just spend a long time on the
tiny details
like
you know I've spent days trying to
figure out the right
pixel radius of a rounded corner for the
for like a button is that a feature or a
bug like uh if somebody I worked with
was spending days on a uh how much the
Border radius should be on a button
I would slap them I'd be like what are
you doing this is not this doesn't
matter and this is not gonna be like
high impact so why are you doing this so
you know is that a
is it a good thing or is that a
byproduct like maybe you do that in
certain areas where it really works then
asks uh I gotta live with the fact that
I do it in these other areas where it
doesn't matter at all
yes so I
you know if if it's not I won't block
anyone by doing that right so like when
we're building the thing like I'll be
very fast and not the bottleneck of the
team
but then in my spare time I'm playing
with things thinking about the next time
we update the design system
and I'm just tweaking little things in
my that's what I do for fun so it's not
like what I'm doing is my work kind of
thing how do you how do you organize
your day uh do you have like uh are you
like focused on one thing do you have
like a morning like okay there's my
to-do list what what how do you how do
you create your day
most of what I do I would say it's
product strategy and design that's like
where I spend all of my time just in
those zones
and we have got like three product teams
at school so three full stack product
teams with back-end front end QA product
manager designer right
um
and they've got three road maps that are
all going in parallel
and I need to think ahead of them like
I've got to dream up like
the whole product strategy and roadmap
and everything
and then I have to reverse engineer into
trunks break it down and then figure out
which team should work on what thing and
sequence it and then I've got to
design the whole thing spare kit brief
that team and stay a few development
Cycles ahead
um
and so I'll either be designing
something trying to figure out a
priority
talking to that engineering team
or chickens doing the final QA check
before we push something into production
I actually think that that's totally the
right way in my opinion that a lot of
companies should run the reason they
don't is because a that's really really
hard so like you're the brainchild you
have to like you probably know every
single thing that's happening that's
incredibly challenging for just about
everyone
number two it doesn't feel good to feel
like a dictator it's like basically
you're you guys are a band and you're
like the main you're you know you're the
main you're the main guy you're Celine
Dion and everyone else is the backup
band that's a weird reference but it is
what it is you're Billy Joel I don't
feel like that's where I went yeah
that's that's where we went you're
sleepy I don't know long hair uh
you're like the guy whereas or I don't
know if I can recover from that whereas
most uh startups it's like it's it's a
lot more decentralized and things like
that but with this type of product it
seems like you're like the the main
person and there's a circle around you
with [__] going on is that right it
sounds [__] exhaust funny example of
this was I remember Sam when you were
running the hustle and I was running my
company we would meet up every couple
weeks as part of our like kind of like
founder Mastermind thing where we would
get together and uh you know I was sort
of drinking the Silicon Valley Kool-Aid
which was like autonomy and like give
people Empower your people and all these
things and I was like you know preaching
to my team like hey
whoever's got the best idea we're going
with you you know oh janitor you got an
idea let's do it you know like let's
make it happen and Sam showed me uh I
meet up with Sam and Sam shows me like a
12-page doc that he wrote out
for some new woman that he hired and he
just go and the document just says uh
welcome here's the things that you're
going to do
um your job is to do this here's how you
will do this step one do this step two
do this
and was just like handed it to her and
was like this is do not deviate from
this I don't want to hear you I don't
want to hear your ideas on this and I
asked you I was like why do this you're
like because people [__] up and I just
I'd either I think this is the right way
to do it and I just need her to do it
this way
no because that I whatever Sam has said
I totally agree with that the problem is
that it's [__] exhausting you know
what I mean like it's really hard to do
that for a long period of time it's not
scalable yeah it's kind of scalable oh
yeah like the engineers I'm not telling
them what to do like in terms of code
right so and then I'm not even coming up
with all the ideas from my own mind I
spend a lot of my time looking at what
our community wants so like
going through our school Community where
people ask for stuff and share bugs and
feedback
then I'll talk to power users I always
find who's spending the most time on the
platform get a top 100 just DM a few of
them get on Zoom talk just talk to them
for hours about it and then I use the
product myself
and then I talk to the team too and so
ideas come from all of these places but
I'm like the filter and the
the sorter in the prioritizer basically
um and then when I go to engineering I
know what the feature should be but they
they might push back on a lot of what I
say based on how easy that is to
implement with code they might be like
oh do you really need to do it this way
because that's going to make the code
messy or why don't you do it this way
that would be way more simple for the
system
and I'll listen to that feedback and
adjust the actual feature because I'm
trying to like I'm trying to give the
the users what they want but I'm also
trying to keep the code clean
and and I'm trying to build things fast
too so I'm like how could we shrink the
scope of this to make it so we could
deliver something faster and
and so it's not like I'm just dictating
to everyone
um there's a lot of collaboration
you know Sean is something I've uh do
you know that Company Jasper yeah have
you talked to those guys is the
Founder's name is Dave or David first of
all I'm on the website of consulting.com
dude well that's what I was gonna say
for one if you go to like uh unsplash I
think it was called or one of those like
stock websites uh stock image websites
for some reason Dave is on the picture
of so many stock pictures I used to use
a picture of him and then I met him I'm
like dude I used your face for a stock
image you're on this like royalty-free
website and number two he used to be
part of consulting.com didn't he so
Jasper's for The Listener is like a I
guess a billion dollar now company that
does AI stuff
um
was he part of your crew
he was a he bought my coolest like many
years ago
um and he was one of our like most
successful students
um he used to sell coaching like
training and stuff but then he he wanted
to get into software so then he did this
thing proof do you remember that that
little yeah yeah
and then that turned into Jasper and did
I why did someone someone told me to ask
you what you think about AI why do they
say that
um
well I think it's like massively over
hyped
and
somewhat like just unnecessary
like I don't know about you guys but gbt
hasn't replaced my Google usage I still
use Google every day
um and I've found no real task for it
honestly
it seemed but the hype is Extreme well
the hype cycle is there around like the
growth and like well it's it's not there
yet but I can see the future of this so
you're not bullish at all in the future
of it
no
I'll take the other side of it
um Sam anything else you want to ask
before we we wrap up no I I appreciate
coming I I want to talk to you again
another time I find you fascinating I
think that you're an original thinker
and I appreciate people like you
thanks uh all right well that's that's
the pod that's it
[Music]